Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we are still blazing
a trail.
For those who take their fate
into their own hands
by working hard...
Imagine I told you
I had a magic trick
to get your kids to enjoy
eating their veggies.
Narrator:
...by working smart...
They're made with
our revolutionary technology.
Ooh.
Narrator: ...by thinking big...
We put everything we had
into this.
...and chasing their dreams...
We had an opportunity,
we took it, we're here.
...and tonight, NBA legend
and sports broadcaster
Charles Barkley
returns to the Tank.
You know how much I charge
for an endorsement?
You're getting
this thing cheap.
People are going crazy
over this.
Do not miss the chance
to get in.
This thing's gonna make
a lot of money.
‐Charles, get in here!
‐Oh, my goodness.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a unique way
to stay safe and secure.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Levi Wilson.
My name is Tim Todd,
and we're from
Oklahoma City, Oklahoma.
Our company name
is Life Lift Systems.
We are seeking $550,000
in exchange
for 15% of our company.
Wow.
Each year,
around 1,200 tornados
tear across
the United States.
Living in Oklahoma,
let me tell you ‐‐
A tornado shelter
can never be too close.
When it comes
to tornado shelters,
there's two main types ‐‐
above‐ground ‐‐
which take up
valuable floor space
you don't have
in your home ‐‐
or below‐ground ‐‐
they're tough to access,
they're prone
to having leaks,
and of course
all the spiders.
[ Chuckles ]
We have created a product
that can be installed
in the comfort
of your own home.
Introducing the Vortex Vaults
telescoping tornado shelter.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Wow.
The only shelter that mounts
right underneath your mattress.
"Auntie Em! Auntie Em!"
It takes approximately
60 seconds to raise.
In tornado season, you usually
have plenty of warning,
or, in a home invasion,
you can actually still
jump underneath it.
‐It keeps going.
‐That is amazing.
It looked like Kevin's crypt
when he comes up.
[ Laughter ]
We're actually coming up with
a pool table
that will do the same thing,
a kitchen island,
and a work bench
that you put in your garage.
Our shelter's been tested
to withstand an EF5 tornado.
That's not just
the 250 mile‐an‐hour winds,
but whatever the winds
bring with it,
like this 4,000 pound car.
‐Wow.
The telescoping safe room
is the perfect
space‐friendly option
to safely accommodate
your family.
Now, Sharks,
who wants to come check it out?
‐I do.
‐Oh, I do.
‐Absolutely.
‐[ Laughs ]
How many people
can fit in there?
Now, Charles,
you're a little bit bigger
than most people, so...
‐Wait, it's scary.
‐We're gonna look at maybe...
I want to see if you can get
in there, Charles.
Maybe one for Charles.
Herjavec:
Charles, get in here!
You brought your book?
Barkley: I did.
‐Oh!
‐Oh! It's scary!
Greiner: Doesn't it, like,
if you close this in...
You got in it okay?
Yeah, I did.
Herjavec:
Doesn't have air circulation ‐‐
how do you breathe?
‐Yeah.
‐So, the air circulation ‐‐
there's vents.
Herjavec:
Where does air come?
The vents are all around
the outside.
They are covered.
Greiner:
Yeah, Robert, look.
Wow,
that's really interesting.
So, guys, if the house
takes a direct hit...
Todd: Yep.
You know those scenes
where all you see
is the old frame
of the house,
nothing else is around ‐‐
is that thing
just sitting there?
Yep.
Yes.
So it won't go up
in the twister.
No.
So, it has to be bolted
to a concrete foundation.
To a concrete foundation,
so how does it work in a house?
So, in a typical house, we
bring it in a piece at a time.
It's all bolt‐together,
so you can get it in any room.
Really.
The cement slab
will be there still
when the house is gone.
Like, you know,
is there any way
that it could come down
while you're in it?
No. There's a battery
shut‐off switch
that kills directly
at the battery.
So, both of you are
from Oklahoma,
where there's how many tornados
would you say hit a year?
So, in Oklahoma, the average
is around 60 tornados.
Wow.
I've actually been
in two tornados.
Oh.
Once when I was a kid,
leveled
my grandparents' place.
The other time was
we were in Tulsa, Oklahoma,
and 50 yards in front of us,
a tornado
whips right through
and wipes out
a Braum's.
Wow.
How much
is the total cost?
Retail price, $6,000 range
for the queen and king size.
Fully installed?
Yes.
Yep.
And how does that compare
to a normal shelter?
Todd: It's ‐‐ It's ‐‐
I'm used to seeing those
underground.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's real comparable ‐‐
the same price.
Basically,
a box that's made out of metal.
And where do people
put it?
That's one
of the biggest issues.
Right now, you have to put it
in your garage,
or you have to pour a slab
outside.
Most people don't want
to give up that kind of space
in their garage.
What are your sales?
We've sold about 119
in the last 3 1/2, 4 months.
‐Oh, wow.
‐119?
Todd: Yes.
Oh, dang,
that's pretty damn good.
How did you sell them?
Mostly through social media
advertising.
Facebook ads.
Have you installed them all?
Not all of those yet.
We're in the process
of setting up dealers.
We did some of
the first installs ourself,
but we're gonna try to go
to the wholesale market.
How much money
have y'all made to date?
I think there's around $550,000
in sales.
And that's
in three months.
That's crazy.
Good for you guys.
‐That's really great.
‐Wow.
Barkley: Break down the numbers
for me.
What are your costs?
The cost of the unit's
around $3,600.
We're retailing ‐‐
wholesaling them out
for about $4,850,
and so our on‐average gross
is about $1,250.
Is that enough margin,
though?
We're shooting
for about $1,000 net profit.
It's not enough.
So, why not charge more?
That's our unknown.
It's the supply and demand.
I don't know
what we can get away with.
Why wouldn't somebody
pay $9,000 for this?
I think so, yes.
Why haven't you tried that?
I think they would.
I can tell you this.
We've been a company
for six months.
So you're still learning.
Yeah.
We had an opportunity,
we took it,
we're here.
Is this
y'all full‐time job?
I actually own
a machine shop.
And we do ‐‐
That's even better, right?
And you're what, now?
Marketing.
Do you have a patent
on this?
Yes.
We have a patent pending,
utility patent
for the telescoping system
for a safe room.
Your price ‐‐ does it include
the installation?
Yes.
So, for $6,000 ‐‐
Too low.
Way too low.
How long does it take you
to install it?
I'll tell you
why it's too low.
Wilson: About four hours.
You can't put a distributor
in the middle.
You can't put a dealer
in there.
You're not making anywhere close
to enough money,
especially since the fact
you're customizing it,
showing up
for four hours.
What's your game plan to sell
a lot of these?
What we want is wholesalers
all over the U. S.
Do you have any wholesalers
lined up today?
We've got two dealers
in Oklahoma.
We're talking with a chain
right now
that has 140 locations.
Cuban: You've got to increase
your margins, man.
Just making 1,000 bucks ‐‐
just the hassle factor
in dealing with it...
Yeah.
Okay.
...and making sure,
'cause people are gonna ask you
to check on it.
How much
have you invested?
We've put in together
$250,000.
250 grand is
no small amount of money.
Right now we're just trying
to find installers
across the nation.
How did you come up
with $500,000 for 15%?
We based it on our sales.
We really think we're gonna sell
1,500 shelters a year.
Or more.
I don't think
the business model's firm yet
in terms of your margin,
because to scale,
you've got to get
another $3,000 in the mix
because they've got to make
1,000, 1,500 bucks
if they're gonna spend all day
putting it in.
Herjavec:
It's a great story.
I mean,
you put in your own money,
you're all in.
I like it, I just ‐‐
I don't love it.
And it's not you,
it's not your business.
Well, before you get there,
don't say it.
Stay in.
[ Laughter ]
Just stay in.
You know.
Just stay in,
because, you know what?
This thing's gonna make
a lot of money.
It's just not for me.
I'm out.
Okay.
All right.
Hey, thanks, bud,
I appreciate it.
‐Thank you.
‐Great job.
It's not really ‐‐
you're not really selling
a tornado shelter.
You're selling insurance.
‐Yeah.
‐That's what it is,
because it's a decision
about your life.
I kind of like
if it's a home prison,
'cause if your kids
are acting up...
Todd: Time‐out.
[ Laughter ]
Why not a crypt,
Kevin?
Daddy's gonna raise the bed,
and you know where your kids
are going.
Like, it's a lock‐down.
That's good.
It's a really interesting idea,
but not for me.
I'm out.
All right.
Okay, thank you.
We appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Guys,
it's a very clever idea,
but for $550,000,
I don't think
I can get my money back,
so I'm out.
All right,
hey, thanks a lot.
We appreciate you.
♪♪
Guys, I loved the idea.
I think you've only touched
the surface of it.
Right.
There's challenges,
though.
And the primary one
is capital.
Yeah.
Because it's not cheap,
and, you know,
you could almost grow yourself
out of business.
But I love what you're doing,
so I'll make you an offer.
Yeah.
I'll offer you
the 550k,
but I want 25%,
and, as part of that,
as we grow,
I'll finance
purchase orders,
all that kind
of stuff.
We'll also introduce you
to home builders.
Right.
So, I love it, too.
Ooh.
♪♪
Narrator: Three Sharks are out.
Mark has offered $550,000
for 25% of Life Lift,
Levi and Tim's
telescoping tornado shelter,
but Lori is also interested.
Greiner:
I love it, too.
I think
it's pretty ingenious,
and I know that
there's a huge market for it.
Lori,
you could put it on QVC.
I ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
You want to know something?
You could lock yourself
in it.
I don't know, but I know
there's a million ways
in which to advertise it.
I think you could sell
just as many...
I don't know.
You have to see it.
This is visual.
Yeah.
As Mark was saying,
I'm gonna give you the $550,000
for 25%.
That's exactly what
I was gonna offer you, so ‐‐
I mean, the difference is,
I'm right there.
Right, and so it's gonna be
really easy for us
to work together,
really easy to build this
out in Dallas
and the entire state of Texas.
Listen, I'm accessible
all the time right by phone,
right by e‐mail.
Are you making them
a firm offer, Lori?
Cuban: That's a different type
of accessible, right?
Yeah, I'm making
the same offer.
It's about going out there,
and...
‐Ooh.
‐So you have a choice.
‐Yes.
‐You've got two Sharks.
Greiner: You do.
Same offer.
Either of you guys
do 20%?
‐No.
Cuban: There's got
to be enough there.
What if we put a royalty
in there?
Hey!
[ Laughs ]
Now you're talking.
You know what?
Look, how much of a royalty
would you pay?
Would you be interested
in doing a $100 royalty?
Sure. All right,
if you want 20%, $100 royalty.
Done.
[ Laughs ]
Wow, same offer.
You guys want
to go in together?
No.
‐Nope?
‐Okay.
Whoa, you boys have to make
a decision.
Just asking.
Look, again,
there's a difference
between being available
on the phone.
Again, not taking anything away
from Lori.
She's great.
Greiner: What do you mean
I'm not available
on the phone?
No, no.
I'm available all the time
for my entrepreneurs.
There's a difference between
being available on the phone...
Who would've thought?
You roll in here
with a telescoping crypt,
and you got two offers.
...going up to see somebody,
and going out
and making appearances
right in the area that matters.
Yeah.
Right.
Cuban:
That's the difference.
Listen, all I can tell you is,
is I know what I do.
All right, Levi,
what are you gonna do?
Tough decision.
He has 51%, so...
Honestly, the 25%'s
a better deal for you
than a royalty,
because it's
a cash‐heavy business.
Levi,
there's a tornado coming.
Mark said he was gonna
finance the P. O. s?
Cuban: Yeah.
Listen, I'm always happy
to finance purchase orders.
There's nothing better
on earth...
Okay.
...to put your money
towards.
Levi,
these are good offers.
‐They are. They are.
‐I've made over 700 products.
Don't let it slip away.
My phone is ringing.
Alert! Alert! There's a tornado
coming down the hall!
Yo, man, you got
to make a decision.
♪♪
Mark,
let's make the deal.
Let's do this.
Wait, do you want to go
the 25%...
Wah.
...or the $100 royalty?
Let's do the 25%.
Smart.
‐Whoa!
‐Congrats, guys.
Appreciate it, guys.
There you go.
‐Oh, man.
‐Congratulations.
Thank y'all so much.
Herjavec:
Who would've thought it?
Thanks, guys.
[ Laughs ]
Oh.
Well.
We got it.
Good job. Good job.
Good job.
Todd: It's been
a huge opportunity
to be on the "Shark Tank,"
and we're getting ready
to take a quantum leap.
With Mark's help, this thing's
gonna grow big very fast,
and I think America's
really gonna love it.
This is actually
pretty cool.
It's scary but cool.
Stay in there.
Okay, take it away.
Aaah!
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 9,
Bethenny Frankel invested
in two women‐owned businesses ‐‐
Snarky Tea...
Our Get Your Ass In Bed
blend
will help you get
some beauty rest.
...and No Mo‐Stache.
Woman: Giving you the freedom
to wax anytime, anyplace.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
Frankel: It's good to have
both businesses together
because I feel like
we have similar goals.
Paschall:
Having Bethenny believe
in women empowerment so much
is very in‐tune
with what our brand is,
what our message is.
Vasseghi: We're currently
working with Bethenny
on a women's solutions kit
like we talked about
in the Tank.
Bra strap holder.
Amazing.
We're creating this kit
to help women in a pinch,
so if there are traveling,
busy moms on the go,
there's always gonna
be something
that you're gonna need
out of this bag.
Instead
of going the gift angle,
this is really
a functional tea.
Williams:
The original line I pitched
on "Shark Tank"
was a little too edgy
for retailers,
so Bethenny and I
worked together
to create something
for a larger audience.
Frankel:
You're still snarky,
but you feel like you're
gonna get the function of it.
Right. Yep.
Frankel: They're hitting it
out of the park.
Combined,
these two businesses
are close to $3 million
since "Shark Tank."
I always send out
to different celebrities
and influencers
these Bethenny Boxes,
and I thought, why not
coordinate all of our products?
‐It's like a confidence pack.
‐It's so exciting.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Exactly.
I work
with Dress for Success.
They help women
to get jobs.
So I thought that
this would be a great thing
to bring over to them,
so let's go over there
and surprise them
with some of these boxes.
Awesome, let's do it.
‐Look who's here!
‐How are you? Good to see you.
So great to see you.
Frankel: Dress for Success
is a nonprofit organization.
They provide development tools
and professional attire
to help women thrive.
We all have been struggling,
broke female entrepreneurs
that have succeeded.
To give back to an organization
like Dress for Success
is on brand.
And we're really excited
to announce
that we'll be donating
a portion of proceeds
from the new products
to Dress for Success.
The women from Snarky Tea
and No Mo had a dream,
and they went for it.
I totally relate to that,
and I want to show women
all around the world
you can achieve
the impossible.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a way
to help babies
acquire a taste
for healthy foods.
♪♪
Hi, my name is Saskia Sorrosa,
founder and Real Flavor officer
of Fresh Bellies,
headquartered
in Westchester, New York.
I am seeking $275,000
in exchange
for 5% of my company.
Wow.
Fresh Bellies is
a new baby‐food company
that sets kids up to be healthy,
adventurous eaters for life.
Imagine eating sugar
for every meal.
Ew.
Herjavec: Ugh.
That's my diet.
[ Laughter ]
Every baby‐food product
on the market today
hides the real taste
of vegetables
by overloading them
with fruit sugars.
By doing this,
we've been training babies
to crave sweet foods
over the good stuff.
Now, imagine I told you
I had a magic trick
to get your kids to actually
enjoy eating their veggies.
You ready?
I'm gonna need your help
with this, so count with me.
One...
Count with me!
All: Two...
Three!
Ahh!
‐Oh!
‐Whoa.
David Blaine's
still keeping a job.
Sorrosa: That's not
the magic trick.
That's just a big mess.
The real magic
is Fresh Bellies.
Fresh Bellies!
Fresh Bellies.
At Fresh Bellies,
we never mask our veggies
with sweet fruit.
Instead, we season
with herbs and spices
like garlic and thyme.
Each chef‐formulated recipe
encourages babies' palates
to grow
so they are less likely
to become picky eaters
later in life.
Fresh Bellies is leading
the shift
towards veggie‐forward food
that moms, babies,
and pediatricians love.
So, Sharks, let's disrupt
the baby‐food industry
and give kids
a healthy, adventurous start
with Fresh Bellies.
‐Ta‐da.
‐Thank you.
‐We are dying to try it.
‐Yeah, we got to try it.
I'd like to pass out samples
now.
Don't trip.
I'll try not to.
Lori, this is for you.
Greiner:
Thank you, Robert.
I have to feed her,
'cause she can't.
I can't.
Hang on, Lori.
Sorrosa: [ Laughs ]
Saskia is such
a cool name.
Me and Mark aren't ‐‐
Thank you. It's Dutch.
But I'm not Dutch.
We're not clumsy.
We don't need a bib.
You have four
of them there,
and the one that has a pita chip
in it
is cauliflower, bell peppers,
and garlic.
The broccoli Swiss chard
has garlic in it.
Lot of garlic.
The golden beets...
It is so good.
Wow.
Yeah. Thank you.
Saskia,
you're basically saying
the idea is to start your baby
on plant‐based
so they never acquire
a taste for sugar.
Is that the idea?
The idea is
to introduce babies
to savory flavors
so that they develop
a palate for it.
So, there's such a thing
called a flavor window.
Between 4 and 7 months
is actually
when we're most recept‐‐
receptive to flavors
as humans.
And right now, in that window,
we've been feeding babies
fruit sugars.
What's your background?
So I used to work
at the NBA.
I worked at the NBA
for 11 years.
What'd you do,
for who?
I was VP of Marketing.
Wow.
You were at the NBA taking care
of a lot of babies.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐No, that'd be today.
We had grown men
back in my day.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
But how did you make
the formulation?
Who ‐‐ Do you have somebody
on your team that made it?
Yeah, so I started making
this food for my daughters.
And when I decided I wanted
to make a business out of it,
I hired an executive chef
who went with me
into a commercial kitchen,
and we were making all
of these formulations together.
And do you have sales
today?
We do.
So, we've only had
six months of sales to date,
and we've generated close
to $100,000 in sales.
By the end of this year,
it will be at $570,000
in revenue.
Good for you.
Saskia,
your product is beautiful.
The packaging's gorgeous.
I get the feeling you've raised
a lot of money to do this.
We've raised money.
How much?
$1.6 million to date.
Oh!         Oh!
Oh!                          Oh!
What valuation?
That's a lot of money.
Our series A has been
on a $7 million valuation,
but we brought that ‐‐
7 million bucks?
You are good
at marketing.
[ Laughs ]
How much does it cost
to make,
and how much do you charge
for it?
So, any product
on the shelf ‐‐
all the typical,
shelf‐stable ‐‐
Oh, by the way,
I didn't mention.
This is also refrigerated,
so our product is
preservative‐free.
That's even worse.
That's worse
because you have to fight
for the refrigerator space.
So, because our product
is so innovative,
and retailers are looking
to innovate
their baby‐food category,
we've had open doors
at every retailer
that we've spoken to.
They're not asking you
for any listing fees yet?
No slotting fees.
Barkley: Can you answer
my question?
How are your prices
compared to the competition?
So, on the shelf, prices range
anywhere from $1.99,
usually for the pouches,
and we retail at $3.59.
Is this really just trying
to train babies to eat better?
The core of our mission
is combating childhood obesity.
The New England Journal
of Medicine estimated
that 57% of kids and teens
will be obese by the age of 35.
That's more than half
the population.
Well, you understand
the challenges here.
The greatest obesity levels
are with
lower‐income households.
Right.
And you're
a premium product.
It's 33% more expensive.
All right,
there's another number
I'm not clear on, Saskia.
You said
your original raise
was at
a $7 million valuation.
Our series A.
And today,
what's your valuation
that you're asking.
$5.5 million.
Yes, yeah.
Why are you doing
a down‐round?
Because we understood the value
of bringing a Shark on,
and so we got our shareholders
to approve being able to ‐‐
Smart, good for you.
O'Leary: Saskia,
the biggest problem
I've got with your deal is
if you can't ever get that
in the refrigerated section.
How are you gonna do that?
We disagree with that.
We think we can, and we ‐‐
How?
Stores want innovation.
We're riding this new wave
of pediatric recommendation
that is all about this.
It's all about flavor.
All about garlic.
We agree, but you're
constraining yourself.
About seasoning your food
not with sugar or salt,
but with real herbs.
You're constraining yourself
by the shelf‐space availability.
Yeah, so, I'll answer that.
And then the other
grave concern,
which is the elephant
in the room
we have
to deal with now ‐‐
How many people want babies
with bad breath?
[ Laughter ]
Imagine, all their friends
don't want to see them.
They don't want to invite them
to the birthday party.
"Oh, that's the baby
with the bad breath."
"Give that baby a mint."
That's the garlic baby!
My concern as a black man,
clearly obesity is a big problem
in our community.
I don't know ‐‐
and Mark touched on it
a little bit ‐‐
if my people
can afford this.
That's my biggest concern.
Yeah,
we want to get there.
I mean,
we want to make good food
accessible to more people,
because they should be
eating this.
They shouldn't be priced
out of a market.
As we scale and we find
more manufacturing partners
and we're able to distribute
to more stores,
we're hoping that we can
get the price down.
Saskia, I think the idea
of palates in training,
man, that's an uphill
marketing battle,
and I think that's gonna take
a lot of money.
You're gonna need, I think,
millions of dollars
to get to
a break‐even point.
It's just not for me.
I'm out.
This could be
an uphill battle.
We understand
that culturally
we've been conditioned
to eat a certain way.
Culture is very difficult
to change.
But that doesn't mean
it's not the right thing to do.
And we have
an unwavering commitment
to do the right thing
in really combating
childhood obesity
and getting kids to eat
the way they should be eating.
I think childhood obesity
is a big problem,
but I don't think
this is the solution,
so I'm out.
Thank you.
The problem for me
was I liked some of them,
and some of them
were really strong.
Mm‐hmm.
Herjavec: Yeah.
Like, I felt,
too strong.
Mm‐hmm.
I think there's some work
to do
on some
of the flavor profiles...
Mm‐hmm.
...um, so that it's maybe
a little more subtle
while you're
introducing it,
so for that reason,
I'm out.
I'm a big believer
that doing the right thing
in business always pays off,
right?
But you've alluded to the battle
you have ahead.
You may have to raise
$50 million, $100 million more
to get
where you want to go.
The amount of dilution
that would come after us
would make it almost, you know,
a non‐ownership position.
And so I think
it's a worthwhile goal.
It's a battle
that's bigger
than what you've presented to us
right now,
and for those reasons,
I'm out.
O'Leary:
Let me just say that you're
a very impressive executive...
Herjavec: Yeah.
...and I don't say that
very often ‐‐
because I was waiting for you
to trip up.
You nailed your numbers.
I like that, I really do.
But I hate your valuation.
I really hate it.
I mean, you don't make
any money,
you got nothing in sales,
it's the beginning
of the journey,
it's a mountain to climb.
If anybody can do it,
you can,
but I'm not going
on that journey with you.
I'm out.
Thank you.
‐Good luck, Saskia.
‐Thank you.
Thank you, Saskia.
♪♪
Sorrosa: We're disrupting
an entire industry,
and it's really hard
to change people's minds,
but we know
we're on to something good,
and we're not gonna stop.
I tried all the foods,
and the one ‐‐
the one flavor
I really couldn't stand
was the $5.5 million
valuation.
[ Laughs ]
That tasted terrible.
That's crazy. She has $100,000
in sales so far.
That's nuts.
Yeah,
that was a big mission.
You got to give her credit
for that.
♪♪
We provided income to over
100 military spouses in 2017.
Thanks to you, a third
of every dollar
went back to the hands
of a military spouse.
We have grown so much
that we were just named
one of America's fastest‐growing
private companies.
So thank you, Mark Cuban,
"Shark Tank,"
and the whole
"Shark Tank" family.
All: Congrats, "Shark Tank"!
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a way to protect
a precious possession.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Adam Haller.
And I'm Desiree Haller.
We are here today
seeking $50,000
in exchange for 13%
of our company, SubSafe.
Sharks,
I grew up on the water,
both boating
and offshore fishing.
I would always pack
an unprotected,
a vulnerable sub
in my cooler,
and after being on the water
all day,
I would pull it out,
only to find a wet,
squished mess.
‐Ew!
‐Boo!
‐No!
‐What's wrong with that?
[ Laughter ]
I've chose not to eat anything
at all
rather than take
one bite of soggy bread.
We were determined to find
a product
that would keep
our sub dry,
but there was nothing
on the market,
so that's when...
Both: SubSafe was born.
SubSafe is the ultimate
sandwich container
and so much more.
It's BPA free,
made from
high‐quality plastic,
making it waterproof,
crush‐proof, and it floats.
SubSafe comes
with three pieces
to protect either a 6‐inch sub
or a 12‐inch sub.
You simply put the sub
in the container,
put it on, lock it tight,
throw it in the cooler,
and rest assured
your sub is safe.
SubSafe is not only
for boating.
Tailgating, camping, hunting,
racing, beach days ‐‐
you name it,
we got you covered.
White, wheat, or rye ‐‐
it all stays dry.
[ Laughter ]
Mr. Wonderful,
don't be an old fogy.
Protect your hoagie.
[ Laughs ]
Oh!         Oh!
Oh!                          Oh!
‐Uh‐oh!
‐Touché, Desiree.
We have samples and subs
for you guys.
‐Perfect!
‐Wow.
That's actually
a great idea.
‐It is a good idea.
‐That is a great idea.
They told us your favorite color
was pink.
Okay, I'm good for pink.
Help me.
Thank you, Robert.
You have
gluten‐free bread.
Cheers. Whoo!
Well, first of all,
gluten‐free is not a thing.
It's my thing.
Stop it, man.
Tell you what, y'all sure do
a lot of eating on this show.
Uh‐huh.
[ Laughter ]
Tell me about it.
This is a great sub.
So, what else
are you putting in this?
Well, I mean,
anything for dry storage.
Your phones, sunglasses,
keys, wallets.
You said it floated,
right?
Yes.
The 12‐inch,
up to six pounds.
Up to six pounds, and the 6‐inch
will hold four pounds.
Greiner: What else
do you have up there?
I can't see everything.
I'm just curious.
So, what we did ‐‐
we strategically
flattened the ends
so that they could be used
as cups and bowls.
How much does it cost?
They are $17.95
on our website.
So the big one is $17?
‐It comes with all three pieces.
‐All three pieces.
So what this allows you to do
is order a 12‐inch sub,
eat half now, cap it off,
throw it back in the cooler,
eat the other half later.
Desiree, what's the cost
to land it ‐‐
to make it
and land it here?
$2.38.
Wow, that's really good.
So what are your sales?
We launched February 26th,
and we are just over $40,000
in sales.
‐Why so low?
‐Yeah.
We're fairly new, and we put
everything we had into this,
so we did not have a lot of
money to play with marketing.
How much
have you invested?
We have $37,000 of our own money
into this.
Do you want to tell them?
Yeah, so let me tell you
about that, um...
‐Huh.
‐Okay.
Um, she was a good girl.
No!
She gave me
three good years,
and I had to let her go.
Herjavec: Adam,
you sold the boat?!
I sold my boat.
Second best day
of a boat owner's life.
I sold our boat.
Our boat.
[ Laughter ]
What would you do
if you don't get the money?
He's gonna have to sell
his truck next.
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: No!
Don't sell the dog!
I'm just kidding.
Is there anything else
that looks like this?
So what ‐‐
No, not at all.
Zero.
'Cause maybe nobody
needs it.
No.
No, it's definitely needed.
People are going crazy
over this.
Well,
they're going $40,000...
Worth of crazy.
Do you have a patent
on this?
We're pending.
On what?
Design.
The largest
sub‐chain restaurant
contacted me
about a week and a half ago,
and they want to roll out
a campaign for summer 2019
with our product
in 1,500 locations.
Is it a national chain?
So they want to buy it
and brand it and give it away?
No. If you come in
and purchase a foot‐long,
then you get a SubSafe
for "X" dollars.
Your biggest problem right now,
Desiree, is the name sucks.
The first thought
I had was "SubSafe"
meaning it's a safe,
physically, like,
you're gonna protect something,
and then "sub" meaning
under something else, right?
Greiner:
I like your name, SubSafe.
If people started
to understand what it was
and get to know what it is,
it's easy to remember,
but I just like to invest
in things that are broader.
That's all.
Because for me, I really have
to hit that kind of market.
Mm‐hmm.
Good job on what this is.
I wish I could take the journey
with you,
but unfortunately,
because it is just
one container,
I'm out.
Thank you.
You've got a big problem
getting the message
out on this thing, okay?
But I'm intrigued with
the deal with the retailer,
which I could really
help you with,
but also I could help you
blow it up on social
a little bit.
How would I ever get
my money back is the problem.
I mean, I give you $50,000?
Ah, why am I doing this?
Herjavec: All right, Desiree,
I can't wait anymore.
I love it.
You're the real deal.
You're so committed.
You guys are so fun.
I don't know if Adam
actually can speak, but, uh...
I'll give you
the $50,000 for...
That's the problem.
[ Laughs ]
For 120%!
That's not enough equity,
and $50,000 isn't...
Let me think about it.
O'Leary: Charles,
what are you gonna do?
Listen, I think
it's a bigger market than subs.
Everybody's not bringing
one sandwich
when they're going fishing.
They're bringing a lot of stuff.
I think there's a wider market
out there for this product.
I think a lot of people's
gonna buy this.
Mark and I have an offer
for you.
We will give you
$100,000...
There you go.
But ‐‐
50/50 each.
We want 25%
of the company.
We think the right way to do it
is to do $100,000
so we have plenty of money
to invest in marketing,
but we need 25% of the company,
Charles and I'd split it,
and you got a real fisherman,
and you got a real
digital marketer,
and we can do some business,
but you got to tell us
right now.
What an ‐‐
That is so amazing.
Wow.
Thank you so much.
I don't even want
to counter.
You guys got a deal.
‐Done.
‐Deal.
This is incredible.
‐Good deal.
‐Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
Great job, Desiree.
Way to kill
Mr. Wonderful, too.
‐Thank you.
Good job, big guy.
‐Well done.
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you.
‐This is gonna be fun.
Thank you so much.
He gets to keep
the truck!
Yes.
[ Laughs ]
Herjavec: What's the biggest
fish you ever caught?
Barkley: Well, I caught a marlin
one time.
And it was stupid, 'cause
I wrastled with this damn thing
for like three hours,
and you couldn't eat it.
[ Laughter ]
I was so pissed.
I cannot believe
this happened.
You did amazing.
I can't believe
you did that.
Turning something from an idea
into a manufactured product
that people now believe in
is just the dream come true.
It's the ultimate dream.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a space‐age technology
to solve
an age‐old problem.
♪♪
Oh, that's cute the way
they ‐‐ they coordinated.
Hi, I'm Taylor.
I'm from Venice, California.
Hi, I'm Sierra.
I'm from New York.
Our company is Zorpads.
We are seeking
a $150,000 investment
for an 8% stake
in our business.
Imagine this.
It's summer.
It's hot out.
You've ducked out of work
a little bit early.
You speed walked
four blocks.
You walk up to
your friend's apartment door.
You open it,
and that's when you see it.
What?
All the shoes are lined up
in the hallway.
You're gonna have to take your
shoes off right here, right now?
You've been wearing these shoes
since 8:00 a. m.
[ Chuckles ]
You're gonna fill
the entire apartment
with the putrid, rotten‐egg,
old‐cheese smell of feet.
Unless you remember
to put in your Zorpads.
This is a Zorpad.
Zorpads are
odor‐zapping shoe inserts.
They're one size fits all,
ultra‐thin, stick in place,
and don't change
the fit of your shoes.
They're super small
because they're made
with our revolutionary
NASA‐tested technology
that packs each Zorpad
with more odor‐destroying
surface area
than a full‐size
tennis court.
People are obsessed
with Zorpads.
You see, they hate the sprays
that belong in bowling alleys,
the powders that turn your shoes
into sandboxes,
or the inserts that bunch up
and make your shoes so tight
it feels like you're walking
in straightjackets.
So, Sharks, you do not want
to miss the chance
to get in on a product
that is ripe
to take over the market.
We have some samples
for you.
‐Cool.
‐Mm‐hmm.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Take the whole thing?
The whole ‐‐
The whole thing.
‐Oh, thank you.
‐You're welcome.
Sierra,
what's in the bottle?
Smith: So, that's garlic.
Very potent.
Garlic.
So we found the most potent
smell that you can find.
Wiegele: All right,
so what you're gonna do,
you're gonna unscrew
the top of the jar,
smell the garlic...
Oh!
‐It's a lot.
‐Yeah.
And now take the swatch
of our revolutionary
NASA technology...
Kevin, don't eat that garlic.
It'll kill you.
...put it over the top,
and just try to smell
the garlic.
♪♪
Amazing, right?
‐Kind of.
I could've really used this
when I played
with some of the funky feet
I played with.
Absolutely.
We figured you had experienced
a lot of funky shoe odors.
Actually, it'll still help me
with Shaq today.
[ Laughter ]
Which one of you
is the astronaut?
Taylor. So, Taylor's got
the SpaceX background.
‐Taylor, I have a question.
‐Oh, seriously?
Taylor,
you work at SpaceX?
So, my background was
in product development
at a large consumer goods
company.
Which one?
‐At Clorox.
‐Clorox, okay.
So, I did product development
for Brita water filters.
I actually earned five patents
for inventions there.
You did.
I did.
Wow.
And so, then moved down
to work in Aerospace
on air filtration
for an environmental control
and life‐support system.
At SpaceX.
Yeah, at SpaceX.
Sierra, what do you do?
I do scaling and growth.
So, my background is primarily
in strategy and operations.
I worked
for a large hospital network.
I was the youngest director ‐‐
male or female ‐‐
at the company,
and then went on to become
chief of staff
to the CEO.
And how did you meet?
At Harvard Business School.
It says "Approved by NASA"
or "Invented by NASA."
Yeah, so, the technology
was tested by NASA
to clean the air aboard
the International Space Station.
The product is not endorsed
by NASA, though.
What's in this?
So, it's
an activated carbon cloth.
There's lots of activated carbon
cloth technologies out there.
‐Yeah.
‐So why is yours different?
So, we actually tested
our product and our material
against all of
the leading competitors,
and we found
that our technology
absorbs up to eight times
as much shoe odor
as the next
leading competitor.
How long does it last
before it has to be replaced?
It lasts for approximately
two months
or we say
up to 60 wears.
Taylor, you said that
this has more odor prevention
than a full tennis court?
Yep.
So, it looks small,
but it's actually filled
with a ton of little micropores,
which are a magnet for odor,
and so if you took
all of those micropores
and laid them out, it would
cover a full tennis court.
Okay, there we go.
So it's a density issue.
Exactly.
So, the fun fact
about our product
is that 40% of people
that use it
have never used
a shoe‐odor‐eliminating
solution before.
Yeah,
but how did they find you?
Yeah, so, right now,
we're doing ‐‐
we do direct‐to‐consumer
marketing.
So we sell them
through our website,
and then we're launching
on Amazon, Walmart, and Jet.
Herjavec: Got it.
How much do you charge for them?
How many have you sold?
They're $5 per pair.
What does it cost you
to make them?
Currently,
it costs us $1.65.
Wow.
At scale,
it'll be 80 cents.
‐Oh, you're making ‐‐
‐And is that in the U. S. A.
or is that...
‐80 cents at scale?
It's all made in the U. S. A.
in New Jersey.
So what are
your total sales?
We've sold $103,000
to date.
Over what time?
Since we launched
in July of 2017.
‐All right.
‐What size shoe do you wear?
9.5 ‐‐
I have smaller feet.
All right, you wear a 9.5.
I wear a 17.
‐Whoa!
‐Almost double my size.
‐How is that ‐‐
‐17?!
That is
truly miraculous.
Oh, my God.
How is ‐‐
We can use one pad a piece?
Yes.
He needs seven.
No. He's gonna need more,
right?
You know, to be honest,
we haven't tested them
on a size 17 foot before,
so we should do that.
And you'd probably need to
with his. It's like...
Do you have a patent?
So, we have a provisional patent
on the product itself.
Third‐party tes‐‐
Do you buy your material
from someone else...
We do.
...or did you create it?
We buy it
from somebody else.
So it's already
out there...
Oh, so you didn't
create this.
...and someone else ‐‐
We don't manufacture
the material, no,
but the patent is
on the construction
of the fabric
and the actual product.
Smith: Yes.
Right, and what do you need
the money for today?
So, two main things ‐‐
marketing and sales.
So, obviously right now,
we are building a brand,
so we want
to invest more there.
Why did you choose spending
your $150,000 on branding?
Why make that choice?
The growth of this business
we do truly believe
will be through retail,
and so we think
by getting into retail,
you naturally are getting
all of the eyeballs
of anyone going
into that market ‐‐
But ‐‐
But you only raised $100‐‐
You're only asking here
$150,000, right?
Yes.
That's not a lot
relative to building
even a local brand.
We have an incredible pitch
for retailers, right?
We're saying...
What's the pitch?
...we can bring 40%
new customers
to that aisle for you.
Oh!
Okay, so, guys, look.
Absolutely.
Harvard Business School
ruined you guys.
I'm out.
‐Aw, that's ‐‐
‐Ouch.
‐Oh.
‐That's a little brutal.
Nobody has foot traffic
to their odor products
in traditional retail
and big‐box retail,
so where are you gonna spend
your money
to create a brand
and drive traffic
where nobody is interested
and nobody goes?
That's why I'm out.
Greiner:
So, here's my thought.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
So am I, by the way.
I'm gonna make you
an offer.
I like this a lot.
Um, quiet.
You guys know.
My secret sauce
is getting product out there
at lightning speed
selling hundreds of thousands ‐‐
perfect demonstrable,
right?
That's my thing.
It's what I've been doing
for 20 years.
I've made a lot of people
millionaires.
But I also have to know
that something works,
so I'm gonna do this
contingent
'cause I care about
my customers.
Oh, a contingency.
So, here's gonna be
the contingency.
Very bad. Very bad.
I'm gonna bring Charles in,
and I'll tell you why.
Herjavec:
'Cause he has big feet?
Any man that has
a 17‐sized shoe, right?
That's a great demo.
Well, Charles?
Right? Yeah.
So Charles could come with me
on QVC.
We'll do the testing
with Charles' shoe...
Smith: Yeah.
...at that third‐party lab,
and we'll see.
Well, first of all, uh,
I love the idea,
uh, so, Lori, I would love
to work with you.
We'll give you the $150,000,
but I think we need 30%.
Ha, oh!
Giving up 30% is crazy
at this point.
Herjavec: Crazy!
No, it's not,
if we make you millions.
So, here's my offer.
I like QVC.
I'm launching BenjiLock
on there.
I sell millions of dollars
of product on QVC.
It's wine
that turns to vinegar.
And frankly ‐‐
And anybody can get on QVC
with a good product.
It has to go through testing
as all my products do.
I like this product
because it can be extended
to other areas.
I'm gonna do the deal,
$150,000 for 20%.
Ooh.
And I think that puts
a little pressure
on everybody else
because I'll focus ‐‐
Not really.
My team will blow
this thing up huge for you.
‐Well, here's the thing.
‐And I like the extension.
Would you rather take 20%
and make hundreds,
or 30%
and make millions?
I make millionaires
out of all my deals.
‐No, you don't.
‐All of them.
By the way, congratulations,
you have two offers.
Well, maybe you have
three offers.
Do I give you
a better offer?
Because Lori's offer
is awful.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Taylor and Sierra have
two offers on the table
from Charles and Lori
and Kevin
for their odor‐eliminating
shoe inserts, Zorpads,
but Robert
may also be interested.
Herjavec: Do I give you
a better offer?
Because Lori's offer
is awful.
Robert, she's got me
this time, though.
Greiner: That's right.
I like the idea
of a celebrity endorsement,
but perhaps we can carve out
some of that equity
for somebody
down the road.
I'm sure there are people
who are smellier than Charles,
with all due respect.
[ Laughs ]
I will do the $150,000
for...
I'll match Kevin's offer ‐‐
20%.
Sierra,
I just want to say this.
You know what they say about men
with little feet.
These guys got
little feet.
[ Laughter ]
I ‐‐ I wouldn't do a deal
with these two little feet men.
Wow.
I trust her.
This is her field,
and I'm riding it with her.
Cuban: Ride or die.
Ride or die.
Greiner:
So, here's a question.
Do you want
the cheapest deal,
or do you want the most
successful‐outcome deal?
I wouldn't give up
that much equity.
Smith: So, first of all,
thank you all for the offers.
Um, Lori and Charles, would you
beat the other two offers?
Beat them?
So you're saying
you want Charles and I
to give you $150,000
for 20%?
For less than 20%.
‐Oh, guys, guys, guys...
‐Oh, yeah.
‐Less than 20%?
I'll do it for 15%.
Herjavec: Ooh.
You know, like I said ‐‐
Like I said.
Work on that.
Work on that, guys.
Bring it on down.
I know what I do.
I make millionaires,
and I'm right in there with you.
So do I.
So, we are not
apples to apples here.
Yes,
you're not Mr. Wonderful.
There's only one
Mr. Wonderful.
Barkley: Okay.
In fairness to me, also,
I'm giving you
a free commercial.
I'm gonna go on television,
advertise your product,
and I'm a lot more expensive
than $150,000, in fairness.
Herjavec: And I think you're not
gonna give up that equity.
I think you're too smart
to fall in for this.
I'll tell you what.
I'll give you the $150,000
for 12%.
Could you match
their 20%?
The original 20%?
Charles?
Lori, I'm with you,
ride or die.
‐Okay.
‐I told you that.
So, is that yes?
If you take the 20%,
we would take it...
Guys.
...and that's, like,
coming in at a 12% and a 15%.
‐Split the difference?
‐We definitely see ‐‐
22.5%.
Still too much.
I think the 20%
would be perfect.
Greiner: It's okay.
You know what?
‐Gonna go out.
‐Okay, we can...
Probably am gonna go out.
Guys, think about this.
Sierra, you didn't start
this company
to give up
that much equity.
You can get Charles
into a deal that works.
That's crazy.
Why would you go down
this journey and give up 20%?
Cuban: Guys, look.
That 2.5% ‐‐
it's not worth
fighting over.
Sure it is.
It's equity.
You know how much I'd charge you
for an endorsement?
You're getting
this thing cheap.
♪♪
All right, guys,
what are you doing?
Lori...
Charles...
Both: We'll take the deal.
‐Yeah!
‐Whoo!
Ah, good!
All right.
Super, super excited.
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Thank you.
‐My pleasure.
‐Congrats, Taylor.
‐Thank you. Thank you.
‐Good job, guys.
‐Congrats, Sierra.
Charles, I got to put
your shoe next to mine.
Okay...
Herjavec: Oh, my.
Cuban: That's crazy.
Crazy.
That's so amazing.
Now that we have Lori
and Charles on board,
we are over the moon,
and we know that just means
lift‐off for Zorpads.
Nice, nice, very nice.
Total lift‐off.
Thanks.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪